what's up guys bang bang it's lunch
money time while wall street is trying
to get rich
the rest of us are just trying to get
our lunch money right i'm
fired up today and so should you look at
this i got some [ __ ] on my lip not
anymore did you see that going on right
there i'm here with plenty evil over
meredith
get your energy up it's thursday it's
thursday afternoon it is 3
14 p.m we are late we so late that you
got to hit the girl with the i think i'm
late
text shout out to lil wayne don't forget
that lunch money is not sponsored by
block five blockbuy has
three products they can buy sell crypto
on a crypto exchange with no fees
you can deposit crypto and earn up to
eight point six percent apy in an
interest bearing account
or you could dance real bad like that or
third you can
get a usl loan against crypto collateral
go to blockfly.com
blockfy.com blockfy.com
let's roll oh now that we got that
out of our system we can move on to the
news and i still got that trillionaire
energy let's go
square will buy the majority of
title which is a music streaming service
partly owned by jay-z
it will put jay-z on the board jay-z
has had quite the month he got title
this is
too high so square will pay 297 million
and cash in stock for title
and earlier he sold the ace of spades
for another
like i forget two technically that was a
different month
whatever he's had a great 2021
you know what i think no you all better
put some respect
on my man's name it's not because people
have to turn down the volume because
they can't hear me
but you're super loud okay thank you
i'll talk real low but y'all better put
some damn respect in my man's name
he's out here just building companies
selling companies building companies
selling companies
he's like a factory he ain't a
businessman he's a business
man didn't you write about this in your
newsletter i did jason
jay-z and jack dorsey teaming up i'm
long let's roll not actually i don't buy
any public stocks but
i would not bet against these two and
jack dorsey knows exactly what he's
doing jack dorsey is one of the best
entrepreneurs of our generation he runs
two multi-billion dollar companies
and my guy gets it it's all about the
creators the entertainers the content
machines
that's the future and when you buy title
that's what you buy is you buy a
relationship
you buy rapport you buy the streets and
that's where all the value is you want
to know who i
think is the greatest entrepreneur of
our time who
her name starts her name has six letters
and it starts with b
and ends in a sarah blakely oh that's so
nice of you
okay what are you talking about oh
you're a partner
that was a hit and run let's go to the
next topic come on we're running out of
time i got things to do
i got things to do today dangerous okay
for you got a little pee head going on
there oh my god
her head look like a peanut be quiet
okay
hoppin rides the pandemic driven boom
and online events to a
5.65 billion dollar evaluation
hop in is a startup it's a remote stop
what is it online platform
it's raised 400 million dollars at a
5.65 billion dollar valuation
go hop and go go hop and go go hop and
go
go hop and go and and we know this
because our friend andreas
invested he i think he was the first
investor in hopkins
go hop and go go hop and go
you need to take your energy and put it
over there you
you have equity exposure to happen
that's great
no you do i know polina is a lp
and our buddy's fun i just learned that
hopkin is an online event
business but i knew that happened was a
hot company
and our friend andres shout out to
andreas klinger he is the king
of remote companies investing yes he's
the king
and he invested in the i think seed and
series a um
worth 6 billion
5.6 billion i just go andreas
go andreas go andreas let's roll
let's roll i'm hopping on out of here if
you don't hurry up and find the link
that you're looking for
she literally clicked on something it
said redirecting and i heard oh god
so okay so the irs has narrowed the
breadth
of its new crypto reporting question the
irs says buying crypto with fiat does
not trigger
tax reporting rules that's interesting
so the irs is saying that
it will not require crypto investors who
simply bought
virtual currency with real currency in
fiscal year 2020
to report that transaction on this
year's tax returns so what does that
mean
they claim that virtual currency with
real currency well i claim that you're
using funny money to buy a real currency
how about that let's put that on the tax
form
they got the funny money buying the
virtual currency or the real currency
okay ready andrew cuomo new york
governor has announced the pilot program
to
test ibm's blockchain-based digital
health app
for proving covid19 vaccination test
results
so basically the health app uses
blockchain technology and will allow
individuals to voluntarily
share their health status through an
encrypted digital wallet
store it on their smartphones without
commenting on cuomo and what you think
about him can we talk about
this blockchain health app no
i ain't talking about this man this man
needs to resign he killed people
and he should absolutely his decisions
his decisions
got people killed where he forced them
to go back into the senior care living
facilities
against the hopes of the people who run
those facilities
i would have nothing to say about this
guy we are not going to decent
talk about the blockchain i ain't
talking about nothing we ain't acting
like this dude
the governor we ain't talking about him
in some normal sense we ain't going to
pretend like
what he's done is all right it's accused
of sexual assault how about we start the
sentencing
sexual sexual harassment i'm sorry i
apologize why don't we start off with
governor cuomo alleged sexual harasser
approves blockchain app that we want to
have that conversation isn't that what
the media always does let's just have a
real conversation
instead we're going to try to normalize
this guy because he announces some pilot
program with ibm
and screw your pilot program how about
we pilot you on out of here i the one
thing i don't like
i don't like bullies i don't like
bullies this dude's a bully
and now he's gonna get bullied by the
law he's a corrupt politician
but also that's his brother all of a
sudden running scared on cnn
i'm not going to talk about my brother
but last year it was all cool we were
it was like a friend's reunion on cnn we
were all just going to chill and talk to
them
i included this topic here listen i'm
just going to warn y'all
she keeps including uh cuomo uh in this
stuff y'all gonna keep hearing about it
are we done yeah go ahead he's gonna get
recalled go ahead
gavin newsom i'm coming for you next
okay
go ahead all right first great apes at
u.s
zoo receive covet 19 vaccine made for
animals these are the first non-human
like animals
to rece yeah the first animals
to receive a vaccine and my friend
caroline was upset because she was like
i'm trying to go to the club and
now there's apes getting a vaccine
before me for me
i actually like that they're getting
vaccinated i am happy tell them the most
important detail of the story
it's an orangutan called karen of course
a karen got uh
gotta covet uh that she's her alone
she's among the first great apes to get
a kobe
vaccine do you want to share your uh
she she is a sick ape though a stick
orangutan she had open heart surgery
yeah i'm all about i'm all about the
vaccine
i would love uh to go into the cage and
just hang out with apes i mean remember
harambe was an inside job but um
do you want to tell the people about
that octopus
oh a cephalopod like yeah cephalopod
i don't know if you all saw the news as
major world news a cephalopod passed
underneath it pass an intelligence test
uh geared towards little children and so
the cephalopods are smarter than how can
you say that word but you can't say
espresso
you say express it because the
that's
is too far below my intellectual
capabilities me personally cephalopod
that sounds like a pop word
uh espresso sounds like a paulino word
okay
it is ask lunch money time hashtag ask
lm
in the comments below mike monaco
hey pomp and pimp i can't believe pimp
is the the orange pills are being passed
out left and right
which big name would you both like to
see get orange
peeled next extreme answers only what is
orange filled mean
for those of us who don't know that
means that uh like they become bitcoin
believers
like red pill but it's orange pill but
why is it orange or not red because the
color of bitcoin is orange
oh is that why or is it because you're
intermediate
intermediate there's no intermediary
with bitcoin either you in or you out
all right who would you like to see who
do you want to see
britney spears no people just think that
you're crazy then
no yeah people think she's crazy she's
not you want to know who i think is
going to come out
who i think that joe biden's going to
come out he's going to try to be all his
hip and stuff like bitcoin you think
yeah we're going to be like we don't
want you
we don't want the politicians the
political leaders we don't need you you
you need them no no we like the
congressmen and the senators i don't
care what i all you outside
i want the people in the streets i don't
want the people in the white house all
the people in the streets
yo joe biden call me if you need to buy
bitcoin though or go
actually joe biden if you want to go
into the comments and you can
ask come talk to the whatsapp scammers
all right why are you being ridiculous
anthony from mark zunik why do you say
absolutely so much
is this a secret drinking game are we
supposed to drink every time you say
absolutely
absolutely tell him tell me about it
i hear absolutely day and night
night and day morning evening lunch and
dinner
i hear absolutely i'm like hey i'm gonna
go
on a walk and he's like absolutely and
then i'm like all right
did you um do your work absolutely and
it's
never absolutely did you take the trash
out absolutely
okay absolutely did you ever try to say
yes but shake your head no
in bulgaria this means no try say the
word
yes no but like a couple of times yes no
yes no you're pretty talented all right
ready moist what up moist counter
okay moist says okay so i'm gonna i was
not emotionally prepared for this moist
answer remember yesterday's question
from me
was what experiencing what formative
experience in your childhood has shaped
you into who you are today very
emotional
he said i'll show you my discipline and
dedication pop 90 days is nothing
to answer the pressing questions he
asked pancakes or waffles
pancakes on a serious note though only
one thing comes to mind as being a major
formative event
event in my life when i was a teenager
within three within a three week span i
lost a
close friend to a drug overdose as well
as my grandfather
i know death is the cliche answer but
that time really hit hard
it was definitely a major turning point
and made me start appreciating
every single day because oh we all have
an expiration date
moist i got a question and then i gotta
go no but that was
that was a lot thank you moist for
sharing that it was a lot but i read it
and i had already time to digest it
because i went looking to make sure
moist was in the comments thank you i
wasn't gonna allow our friend here who
messed up one time
to mess up again i'm gonna make sure
moist moist ain't gonna stop he gonna
comment for 90 days straight watch
i already can call it i already know uh
absolutely
i almost said it but i know you did um
my question for moist if you could buy
one stock what is it and why
and if you give me some dumb answer i
ain't gonna be happy but if you could
buy one stock
what is it and why does the profile
count
does it have to be an actual public
company or maybe future stock
yes it has to be a real public company
all right guys disqualified all right
guys
i thank you so much for putting up with
my wife
she annoys me sometimes she bugs me
she actually really bothers me sometimes
she is so annoying that i'm like oh my
god i got a migraine and she's like
really and i'm like not really but like
because i
am too mentally tough to get mike rings
but like can you please leave me alone
and then she hits me with anthony and i
say
just kidding and look she's not getting
mad i'm in so much trouble but i'll see
you guys tomorrow
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five
so go check them out there's a link in
the description that you can click on
i'm an investor
a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block flies my second favorite thing in
the world behind paulina they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to eight point six percent
interest on an interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to 8.6 interest on a deposit in an
interest bearing account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends